[Music]
it's about 4:16 in the morning arrived
at the airport ready to go I'm Jake one
of 40 finalists competing for the
hundred thousand dollar children it all
comes down to a two-minute pitch in one
life-changing decision to drop out of
school and pursue our dreams this is
team Technorati
I'm working on a product called bambina
and I'm tracking vital signs in babies
hive is a crowd-sourced supercomputer
prime is a modular wheelchair which is
easily customizable my idea is to
predict horse a platform that allows you
to create multiplayer real-time
educational games I'm the founder and
designer of an app called finish I have
created an algorithm that I named doc
bot I'm here to end cancer in two short
days we've all gotta face the lightning
round
a two-minute pitch where we have to
convince the judges that our ideas are
worth a six-figure investment my product
is a comprehensive radiation shield
composed of four layers carbon nanotubes
polyethylene boron nitride nanotubes and
radiation decimeters my whole thing
isn't the radiation set it's going to
Mars last year I had like a little
YouTube sensation Fame I made a prom
with your request to Kate Upton that
went viral
I'm usually confident like I'm always
like oh yeah I'll be fine I can match up
with it and say when I come here and
it's like the NBA of IQ I look at it in
science and technology and I'm like a
third string Division one walk-on who's
just struggling to get on the fellowship
is to your program where we have
$100,000 to 20 young people a year to
take their biggest ideas out of the
classroom and then to
world all that we require of you is that
you're under 28 and that you're driven
to try and do things to change the world
but here's the catch
anyone who wins a fellowship has to drop
out of school which makes things a
little more controversial my mom
actually took me aside and she said Alex
drop out of school my parents told me
you're an idiot if you drop out if I get
the fellowship I'll definitely drop out
of school a big factor in my decision is
USC I'm on a scholarship they're almost
a college experience almost living with
kids in a dorm on the other hand I'll be
at 18 or 19 with the connections of an
incredible community and the actual
ability to change the world so
congratulations to all of you for all
the hard work that you've done that's
helped bring you here today good luck
and whether or not you end up receiving
a tool fellowship know that your work is
important and the world really needs
things that matter from the finalists
I've talked to nobody has prepared a
two-minute lightning talk it's so
nerve-racking all the lights shining on
you like 500 people who knows how many
people in the audience the money is a
very crucial thing it will enable me to
have freedom hopefully we won't screw it
up too badly comments isn't slowing that
definitely exists this weekend but I
don't want to let it overcome me while
I'm here
40 finalists 20 winners who here's got
what it takes to be $100,000 college
drop back and what would you do
take the grant or stay in school let us
know in the comment section and be sure
to subscribe to the wire channel for the
next episode of team Technorati when the
games really began
you
[Music]